there's a prayer that we do that says if
this is good for me give it to me and if
it's not good for me then keep it away
from me and every time I make that
prayer I'm like but what if God takes it
for me my name is Mai Zafar I'm 16 years
old and I am a Muslim boxer from
Minnesota I love boxing
but I love my religion and I want to be
able to do both without compromising
another I'm not allowed to fight with my
hijab because in the rule book it says
you can only fight with the like
sanctioned uniform which is the trunks
in New Jersey all right really
yeah I cover to show my faith and my
like self-respect
I think it's ignorance when people say
just take it off it's like to me it's
like would you fight with no clothes
people in the Muslim community not
people that I know but online it'll be
like this is not Islamic girls shouldn't
be doing this to say that I can't
because I'm a girl it says nowhere that
I can't do anything a guy can do before
bossing I wished a girl you know and
then boss he showed me that no I grew up
being a girl means that you're strong
and I can push harder than most guys
because I have discipline I have the
strength that a lot of people told me I
didn't have I've talked to local
officials and the officials with like
USA Boxing and they've been helpful the
antares I hit a director has asked like
international for a waiver so I'm just
waiting to hear back from that
I've worked so hard for it and I keep
working hard every single day that for
them to tell me you can't fight it's
like what do you mean like I of course I
know how to and I'm good at it maybe the
rules say I can't but I think the rules
will change I want to fight with my job
and Under Armour and the 21x eventually
that's my dream I will be able to fight
someday soon hopefully but if not I
don't care how old I am
I'm gonna train and tell them
[Music]